those who have been watching some of the
films that I've been making in my new
small
Dojo I'm trying to make them more in the
podcast uh way so that you can listen to
them rather than just watch my face
talking
away and I've named some of
them uh just chitchat because
I find that's my best way
of talking sometimes just not rehearsing
anything but just saying what I think
what I feel at the
time here in the
UK uh I would be known as a very blunt
person but in the
USA uh when I get
comments they say you're a very candid
person
person so obviously it meaning the
same I tried to say what I
think I don't wish to hurt anyone it's
just
that the way I was brought up as a
child I decided that um why should I
perhaps rebelling why should I say what
people want to hear I mean can play that
game and most people are playing it for
the their whole
life agreeing with other people thinking
before they
speak um I've been told many times when
I've upset people on
the on the
tatami by other senior teachers my own
rank Tony you shouldn't have said
that but the problem is by not speaking
honestly and truthfully as it comes from
you it's as if
you're and you know you can't fit
in and um fitting in seems to be the
whole process
of the people on this
planet I used to teach three times a
year in
Russia and now because of the
dictatorship wanting
to make a new world
order in my lifetime I don't think I
should be going back there ever again to
to
teach I still love my students they're
normal human beings and they out of the
seven continents of traveled the five
continents I've been into we are all
even though it's different languages
speaking the same thinking the same and
Desiring the
same it's only those stupid
dictatorships that seem to want to rule
all those beneath them I say beneath
because they hold the power not that
anybody should be beneath anyone
anyhow this is not a party
political uh broadcast to
you it's really talking
about something I've recently read
from shean n Juan
nin and
um I agree
100% you may not have seen it yet it's
on the Davis
website
posted on the 3rd of October
2023 I urge all
teachers to read this think about
it
because I read it and I agreed 100% with
his
words and what he
thinks needs to be
within a good
akoka from a beginner all the way
through to
teachers what I don't agree with is that
it can be
achieved the
minority of people doing aido in the
world
today are not what him and
I
trained under and the way we
trained to me this can never be brought
back so his dreams in my
opinion are wonderful thoughts but can
never be
achieved I'd like to go into some
reasons why perhaps in this film or in
others that I will talk on this subject
about
traveling in these five continents what
I've found
is the people doing
iido in the way that he would
like where you get the student
absolutely immersed dedicated into the
art they want to do everything so you
you train their body to what I would
consider almost Olympic level you know
the fitness the flex
flexibility
stamina every part of a human
body's uh
cardiovascular and their whole
being must be tuned and
toned far beyond what anybody could ever
imagine one could get
to they normally train up to six times a
week in Russia
and this is going back when I first went
there in the early 90s just
after the end of the Cold
War when uh they started to want the
things
that at the moment they're saying or I'm
saying the the the government is saying
the West is evil the West is
bad and yet over 10 years of going there
when they had
nothing of the
west where along the road you would be
looking in a car you'd be in a ladder
yourself Russian made Russian
built and there would be nine laders and
different various Russian cars mosovich
other
[Music]
sedans and you perhaps would see one
Volvo one BMW every every 10 making the
10th
one 10 years on from
that the odd one out what's the ninth
car will possibly be the
ladder they'll range from Japanese cars
to every continent across the world that
makes
cars and when I spoke to them
about the
modernization they love the Multiplex
Cinemas the Pizza Hut the
McDonald's the Kentucky Fried Chicken
and when you go to these places it's
full of young families and young
people I'm trying to give you a
picture of every time I hear now on the
news the West is evil the West is bad
the actual Russian
people embrace the West's way of living
because it means that they have freedoms
they have money in their
pocket now this is talking about iido so
I'm giving
you a sort of a
talking of what I found then and
now and why I say that we can't go back
in
time to the desires and hopes that Juan
new Shan is writing
about I will get lots of criticism I'm
sure sure from those around the world
about what I'm saying but I'm telling
you it from my heart and
and what I genuinely
think I built this
dojo and it's
because I used to have a large Dojo what
would hold 40 people now this Dojo will
hold 10 at the outside possibly six
comfortably eight with a squeeze
10 when we're looking at detail or
giving a
lecture it's it's not me that needed the
small
Dojo it's the times that we've we've
come to where there's not enough
students to build a large Dojo or to run
a large dojo in the
UK over the last 20 30 years the
decline in iido in the UK especially and
I think around the world in what I'm
going to say the Western
de democ is
where they've got all the things that I
was telling you that now the Russians
have got or did
have the world has
changed and it's become a strange
place and I'd like you to consider
that what I've said
here and I will continue it in a and
another
film but why I have to make short films
is the same reason why we don't have
aikidoka dedicated as we did in the
past and that is because nobody has time
nobody wants to listen to a long drawn
out talk by
me when I post something on Facebook
let's say I post a a 15minute
film or in this case
podcast I will get likes coming back
within 2 to three minutes as if
somebody's fing them from a machine
gun they don't even have time to have
seen the film if it's 15 minutes long
and yet they're liking
it so this is the world that we're now
cont attending with so how will we ever
go back to having devoted aikidoka who
really do want to find those senses
iido not just the
technical not the
spiritual you know not the dancing
Styles not the hard eat rocks
style not
MMA thinking about taking them on with
aido to me iido is lost and will be lost
forever in the Democratic
world because other things have taken
place I hope so far
you're at least thinking about what I'm
saying even if not enjoying it and I
will continue it in the next film